foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
standing up for women's rights used to
mean fighting for Equal Pay equal
opportunities and equal respect now it
means fighting for the very word woman
itself to even exist more people in this
country are women and women will knock
on doors campaign donate to parties and
vote when you see the leader of the
party
unable to say whether people with
penises are women what was your reaction
I
you know it's dystopia they'll never
have periods they'll never experience
that you know it it does hinder many
many females yes female children
[Music]
you know my general view of the world's
gone completely crackers well there was
a brilliant piece written in today's
Daily Telegraph by trans athlete Tina
Daniels who says she considered entering
events in 2012 London Olympics after
undergoing gender realignment surgery
from a man to a woman I could have won
Gold in every category but she wrote
this was something I couldn't bring
myself to do while others have worked
tirelessly for the chance to realize
that same dream because of my unfair
Advantage I would just be taking a
deserving spot away
it's fairness that my next guest is
concerned about today what Athletics is
looking at increasing restrictions on
trans women but not Banning them
completely from women's sport and
British shot put Champion Amelia
strickler says it could screw women in
her sport her words in her own excellent
piece about this and Amelia you join me
now so I better explain to you as why
you sound a little bit American you're
born in Ohio yeah you're British
American you compete for for Britain
yeah you've been a British champion and
shot put in twice and you'll hopefully
will be competing for GB in the Olympics
yes
talk to me about this issue because I've
been talking about this as a man for a
long time yeah but in the end I think
it's a debate that has to be won by
women
it seems to me just grotesquely unfair
that you can reduce testosterone as much
as you like but what you got with Jesus
Caitlyn Jenner is very strong about this
you can't reduce physical size power
body mass all the things you accumulate
in a male body for many years is that
really at the heart of this yeah
um ultimately you know the hormones are
not going to take away that male
Advantage the hormone suppressors or
um yeah it's just it's not going to it's
not going to take away that male puberty
you know there are physiological things
you can't change skeleton sizes hip
angles lung capacities you know
obviously the muscle and some people you
know transition later in life don't they
so they may have trained
as a man for many many years biological
male right and then all of a sudden
decided to identify and the common theme
if you take Leah Thomas a swim in
America or you take some of the
sprinters in Connecticut be smashing
women's records uh or Laurel hubbardies
in New Zealand uh weightlifter who
transitioned and competes against women
the common theme is that as male
performers they were pretty mediocre but
when they start competing against women
having transitioned and said I'm now
identifying as female they start
smashing records which may never be
beaten in some cases I mean they're
basically rewriting women's sport
exactly and they're taking away a lot of
opportunities from other women that have
worked so hard to be where they are
um Leah Thomas winning the national
title
you know they were they were never good
enough to do that in the in the mail
category nowhere near good enough and
you know it's it's really about keeping
women's sport Fair where's he gonna go
this I mean if if while Athletics are
going to be so gutless as they currently
being where they're just basically
sitting on the fence and hoping this all
blows over it's not going to blow over
because more and more people are now
identifying as a different gender this
has become a huge phenomenon now around
the world which means more and more
athletes are going to be transitioning
and saying okay now I'm a woman now what
happens if you are a high performing
male athlete in any discipline and you
see an opportunity if you're cynical we
know there are cheats in sport right we
saw it of course from Lance Armstrong to
others and they go you know what here's
a way for me to make myself extremely
rich and famous I'll just put my hand up
say I'm female for three years whenever
things earn hundreds of millions and go
back to being a man at the end of it
exactly what's the top someone doing
that it's happening at Grassroots level
as well already
um you know that's even if it's just a
park run surely that means something to
someone to place you know high enough
and you know they'll never have they'll
never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes female
children it's a real issue even you know
Dino this summer said you know I've had
lady issues and she didn't perform well
when she didn't perform well that day
and you know it's understandable what
reaction have you had since you wrote
this piece and went public it was a
brave thing to do I've had very good
reactions I've had a lot of people say
you know thank you from me thank you
from my daughter
um you know this this this means a lot
so much to so many you know women and
and men and you know everyone seems to
have have a really positive reaction to
it um obviously any negativity of course
you're gonna have some um you know some
want to say I'm not even British but
right so they start being racist yeah
exactly and they and you've been accused
of being transphobic which is the
default position for anyone that dares
to raise concerns about this issue you
have to be a transphobe even though
at all right no I I fully think they
should be included but there's a way to
have them be included and not have it
harm female Sport and biological females
competing in the in sport you know
completely swimming they did an open
category and a female category to
protect the female sex and to protect
athletes to have a trans category and
just build that up and just have a third
you know but why not I mean yeah what
what's happening in a moment is just not
fair it's not fair to work and women's
rights are being eroded at the altar of
political correctness that's all that's
happening and people are terrified of
saying this is wrong that's why I really
wanted to get you in and I really admire
you for what you've done it's a really
bold thing have you heard from the
British athletic bosses or not I have
not but a lot of other big names my
peers you know people I'm on teams with
big names people that people would know
these names they agree with you strongly
support me but obviously I think you
know people are scared to speak out they
do not want the label of transphobic
they do not want their contracts to
potentially be in Jeopardy which I can
understand Athletics is not a wealthy
sport we're not making football money
um but you know it is important to me
and you must have known when he wrote
this piece that this should backfire
horribly it might be the end of your
career yeah I mean that's a that
literally it could be it seems
anything could have happened to you it
did cross my mind um but I am so
grateful for everyone who's reached out
positively because it really is touching
to hear that you know someone's daughter
is looking up to me just for speaking up
I didn't expect
good for you we need more people with
your guts to do this then then this
debate can be had properly and fairly
because nobody wants to be unfair to
trans athletes but I don't think they
should be allowed to just dominate
women's sport which is incredibly unfair
to women born to female bodies just
period period but it is full stop as
people say in this country oh I'm
turning all American then inappropriate
there
um finally one question for you what
makes you wake up one day and think I
know what I'm going to do with myself
I'm going to run along and Chuck an
eight pound weight 18 meters
um this is what you do yes I I was young
and got involved in athletics and you
know I loved I loved all the events but
this one this one I seem to excel at and
I just stuck with it and it's been quite
a journey and you know it still makes me
happy whatever amazing I think it's an
amazing thing to watch it really is it's
so hard to actually move and then throw
something that far that weighs eight
pounds it's just a I could I couldn't
throw it out of the pitbit
Amelia you're very gutsy keep speaking
out uh others will follow you but as
always it takes the first people over
the top to just to call it for what it
is and you've done that so thank you
very much thank you thank you so much I
hope I do hope more people speak yeah
because it's very important this has to
get addressed properly yeah and best of
luck see you at the Olympics yeah many
people you're all kind of guts at the
Olympics it takes a bit of mental
strength courage resilience don't take
this nonsense if you can take down the
wokies you can certainly win Olympic
gold I'm right behind you Amelia good to
see you thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
standing up for women's rights used to
mean fighting for Equal Pay equal
opportunities and equal respect now it
means fighting for the very word woman
itself to even exist birthing people
menstruating bodies with vaginas
individuals with a cervix chest feeders
womens we mix walks we're minks how do
you even say those words these are all
terms used to describe an adult human
female everyone from the British Health
Service to the former first aid of the
United States Michelle Obama
let's be clear the Cambridge dictionary
dictionary now says an adult human
female is actually an adult who lives
and identifies as female that they may
have been said to be a different sense
of birth
do you know this week the government of
Jersey launched a public health campaign
aimed at women which said if you are a
transgender man a gender non-conforming
person or a signed female at Birth and
with a cervix you can book your free
cervical screening today what about
women
in Jersey
what happens to them
why have they been airbrushed from all
these communications
the Brit award surrendered to a
ridiculous Crusade by going gender
neutral I warned at the time this would
backfire and would just lead to probably
all male shortlist yeah well guess what
happened the best artist category of the
year is all male nominees
I could have told them that because I
did tell them that
there's an Insidious campaign to protect
the very tiny percentage of the
population who identify as transgender
by erasing half of the world's
population who identify as women
and make no mistake it's a dirty
campaign
that's an elected representative of the
Scottish Parliament using rather
unparliamentary language to describe
women who've argued against the S P's
gender bill and the same rally last week
protesters Wade science saying
decapitate turfs now Turf stands for
Trans exclusionary radical feminists
it's really just a smear word used
against any woman who dares to stand up
for women's rights so these be quite
kind equality angels are literally
calling for women to be beheaded the
term for that too it's hate speech and
anyone who dares to call it out is
branded transphobic but it's not
transphobia to say that trans women born
to male bodies cannot fairly compete
against female athletes it's not
transphobic to say that women have a
right to feel uncomfortable about
transitioning men being in their
changing rooms and safe spaces it's not
transphobia to think it's utterly
terrifying that a muscle-bound
shaven-headed male rapist can change
gender often committing the most heinous
crimes against women and then be sent to
a female prison
Adam Graham savagely raped two women he
met online when he first appeared in
court in 2019 he did so as a man
by the start of his trial he was now
apparently a woman now she is heading to
a woman's prison full of the kind of
women that he raped
it's almost Beyond parody this but it's
happening
and it's happening in Scotland where the
SMP wants anyone age 16 to be able to
self-identify as the opposite sex with
no medical diagnosis whatsoever
well very few people have had the
courage to speak out about this but one
of them one of the more notable people
is labor MP Rosie Duffield who did speak
out about it
the bill clearly conflicts with the
equality act and would have
repercussions for women for women across
the UK and given the previous uq does he
not understand how vitally important
this is at the moment
quite extraordinary scenes Rosie
Duffield there being heckled by her own
labor colleagues for a speech in which
she defends women's rights to safety
she's faced these ridiculous allegations
of transphobia for years and ironically
it all began when she liked this tweet
by me and I was responding to a
ludicrous tweet from my former employers
at CNN where they just wouldn't say the
word woman
and I said surely you're talking about
women not individuals with cervixes
about a cervical cancer screening story
and Rosie Duffield liked it
and for that all hell broke loose and
she got abused so badly and had so many
death threats she had to temporarily
come off Twitter
she's not a trans folk I'm not a
transphobe as I've said many times I
believe trans people deserve rights and
respect like everybody else
but I believe passionately in women's
rights and protecting those too and so
does Rosie Duffield I'm glad to say she
now joins me
well welcome
[Laughter]
um I mean that's quite an intro when you
read it all out isn't it yeah and you've
been at the center of this dormant can I
start by apologizing for the Tweet which
you liked which entered you into Miss
Bear Pit of Mayhem let's go back to that
because I read this this tweet from CNN
in which they shouldn't be going out of
their way to cover a story about a
cervical cancer screening report in
which they were trying not to use the
word woman an individual with a service
and I thought this is preposterous yeah
you're talking about women aren't you
you liked it and then you followed up
and said actually I I just think women
have cervixes yeah
absolutely and then what happened uh and
then I got
um all kinds of like you said all hell
break loose I mean I thought it was a
good way a sort of safe way to kind of
put my opinions out there and the
opinions of all of the women that I
spoke to all of the time who were asking
someone to say something about this you
like you you did a tweet and I thought
okay I like that it's just a tentative
kind of toe in the water and it was kind
of amusing what you were saying and you
know it was a stupid issue it was funny
it was so ridiculous like you said and
uh then the people that started sort of
calling from my beheading you know
metaphorically
um
there is that as well but but you know
people calling for me to lose the whip
in the party are all the sort of people
that were running or leading labor
societies and that's where we've got the
problem in the party I think so you get
all this abuse so bad you end up
temporarily coming off Twitter because
it was so vile but what is even more
shocking to me is that your own labor
party colleagues from the top down
basically threw you to the Wolves yeah
they didn't want to go there this is too
toxic yeah they couldn't even say what a
woman is in fact it's against armor your
boss at the labor party
um he was asked directly whether a woman
had a penis uh by the Ferrari listen to
this
a woman can have a penis
look I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
no no I just is it transphobic to say
only women have a cervix well it is uh
something that uh shouldn't be said it
is not right but Andrew I don't think
that the rosie Duffield should not have
said that can you explain to people
watching why she should not have said
that well Andrew I don't think that um
we can just go through various things
that people said
I found it extraordinary I mean I like
Hearthstone I get on very well with him
with fellow Arsenal fans it's a good
time to be an Arsenal fan I gotta say on
this he's really LED himself and the
party down because you've got to be able
to say what a woman is if you want to
lead a political party absolutely it's
not difficult it's an adult female but
more people in this country are women
and women will knock on doors campaign
donate to parties and vote and if women
don't feel that we're represented that's
a serious State of Affairs ballistically
and I had met with Keir I think the aide
who talked about me so that I was always
always in that of his office I met with
him once well Matthew Doyle Center all
the time yeah I met him once I mean
let's actually play The Clue this was
leaked by Guido Forks the media website
let's listen to what he actually said
Matthew door
yeah I mean she's been able to see if
there were a number of times but she
also then usually sometimes
there are people that countries
[Music]
I mean we put the we put the words up so
you because obviously it was it was
quite a saint what he was saying we
managed to put the words up there so you
could see it it's really quite
extraordinary this guy's ahead of Labor
Communications he's the voice of the
party on behalf of Kia stama and there
he is actively briefing against you as
it turns out lying about the number of
times you've seen kirstan he said you're
in and out all the time and mocking you
for not spending enough time in your
Canterbury constituency saying you're
spending too much time with JK Rowling
yeah I mean I've never met this man I I
have no idea how he thinks he knows
those things how many times have you
been in kirst Armor's office I was there
the week before he gave that interview
to Andrew Ma and I was trying to explain
my point of view I was trying to explain
that lots of women's groups were in
touch with me that I had had nearly 400
Bunches of flowers and cards and emails
and they never stopped they have I've
not met a woman
who would disagree with you I've not met
one I don't know where they exist these
people yeah but I have not met a woman
and I've traveled far and wide in the
last two years I've not met a single
woman who looks me in the eye privately
and says well it's all ridiculous of
course we know what a woman is there are
a few labor MPS there are a few I know
they exist because I see the hell that
you have to go through but just to be
clear on Kia Starman how many times have
you been in his office since then uh not
once not once no so this is complete
nonsense being skewed too I mean but
this guy doesn't know me doesn't know
anything about me but it's a very clever
line isn't it I I knew I'd heard that
they've been briefing about me before
this but of course I had no proof it was
just this kind of feeling that you know
I knew that they weren't pleased with my
stance on things but to hear him I mean
that's so clever to start sowing the
seeds of Doubt oh maybe she's not in her
constituency and then it gets through to
my what's the truth about that of course
I'm there every single week like every
other MP you know I live there I've
lived there since 19. how many times
have you seen Jay care running
personally in the last two years I saw
at Christmas so the famous lunch
and that's it that was another look that
was you've seen her a couple of times
yeah and we talk most days actually
you're not spending most weekends up in
Scotland plotting that would be lovely
but no I'm at home in Canterbury well
we're going to come to her in a moment
on kirst Armor though when you when you
saw him what did you say to him
um I just explained in the situation I
said I'm so sorry the story at the time
was that I wasn't going to conference
because of all the death threats I was
so embarrassed by that story getting out
there I hadn't said I hadn't announced I
wasn't going to I told a couple of
friends that I thought it was a good
idea not to go it was his first big
speech I didn't want to be the headline
ironically I was the headline for about
three weeks about that and uh so I said
to him you know we've got into this
situation will you meet with these
groups will you hear what I've got to
say and he was really sympathetic he
said oh I haven't heard of this group
labor women's declaration 8 000
signatures to say that they want this to
be discussed they want people to to talk
about it freely and since then a couple
of conferences have passed and labor
women's declaration are not even allowed
to have a stall at neighborhood and then
you know a few days ago we see you being
openly mocked and jeered by your own
side in the comments yeah for standing
up for women's safety I mean Ben
Bradshaw was one and who was the other
was another male member right yeah this
is the see a little bit of this
the bill clearly conflicts with the
equality act and would have
repercussions for women for women across
the UK and given the previous uq does he
not understand how vitally important
this is at the moment
quite extremely two male labor MPS yeah
Lloyd Russell Moyle and Ben Bradshaw a
former Minister he was heard shouting
absolute rubbish yeah as you defended
the need for spaces segregated by sex
yeah how have we got to misplace Rosie
where what seems to me to be just the
obvious Common Sense thing to do is
being eradicated at the altar of
political correctness I think it's
activists I think it's the kind of
people if you are based in London and
you're leading a party where you know
your staff and all your associations and
labor societies are the same kind of
people who are very nepotistic party I'm
finding out I guess the others are as
well I don't I can't speak on that but
you're surrounded by the same people the
same activists the same people are on
the NEC or the boards of this that and
the other you're just hearing the same
voice when you see the leader of the
party secured armor unable to say
whether people with penises are women
what was your reaction I
I speechless really I mean
I mean it didn't I don't know what to
make of it half the time it sort of
seems funny half the time it's really
scary I mean I've had high profile women
Dame Joan Collins was one a great friend
of mine who didn't want to say what she
thought a woman was anymore because
didn't want to get the aggro that would
come from answering the question that's
what we've got to where some of those
glamorous women of all time like Joan
just feel that they've been cowed by the
mob it's really sad and they don't want
to go into that Bear Pit that you've
gone into you know how vile it can be
but I have to because I have hundreds of
thousands of women contacting me and I'm
involved in lots of women's groups and I
know how they feel and I think with a
party of Working Class People and
working class women those are Our Roots
the kind of people that are likely to be
in the kind of prison that you talked
about at the start of the show a working
class women that's our job and I will
continue I mean that story of the of the
man who raped two women yeah and tonight
his ex-wife or her ex-wife has now
broken her silence and apparently says
she she thinks he's scamming everybody
is a man just using this as an excuse to
get into women's prison which is why his
rights as a rapist are something we're
talking about anyway right you know that
is absolutely agree let's take a short
break Rosie after the break I want to
talk about your friend JK Rowling is who
tweeted this Rosie Duffield an
ex-assistant teacher single mother
survivor of domestic abuse one labor a
seat they thought was unwinnable post
Corbin she was returned upon an
increased majority and this is how labor
repays her let's discuss that after the
break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
my special guest Rosie Darfield Abraham
peace Rosie your friendship with JK
Rowling I mean you're joined I guess by
this issue in a sense that she she was
very supportive of you publicly because
she could see the hell you were going
through she's gone through similar stuff
for expressing similar views of trying
to support women's rights to safety and
and so on
tell me about JK and your friendship
um she's much funnier than you would
imagine very funny we all kind of we've
got to sort of you know everyone has
secret WhatsApp groups we've got a
secret DM group on Twitter we just kind
of keep each other going really on a
daily basis people like Julie bindle and
me well there's a funny picture actually
because I think you and Julie Bendel uh
you were withered you wore a t-shirt
with you and JK running as dinosaurs
after David Lammy yeah Labor uh Shadow
Minister called turfs dinosaurs that was
the gift that really kept on giving and
because you know I've been sent dinosaur
jewelry dinosaur chocolate
it's what do you what I mean what the
wave labor party have responded
it seems to me they're siding with
people who are waging an Insidious war
against women's rights so what does it
say about them from secure downwards I
think it is fear I think all of it is
fear yeah I think the fact that we've
got so many very senior men so the
Chiefs of Staff the general secretary
Kia himself you know all this head of
comms or whatever it is he does they're
all men they're all men based in London
I don't think that they're listening to
people I don't think they're hearing
people what's your message to kirst
armor tonight if he's watching this I
think I'd like him to to listen to
women's groups I'd like to to know that
he's met with those people that are
really concerned about should he should
he listen to you I mean should you not
that would be nice if you want to have a
definition of a woman are you the person
you should go to could you help him with
that I'm a particular expert in that but
it would be nice too you know what a
woman is because you are one I thought I
did yeah it'd be nice if we just had a
dialogue you know he's my colleague and
we're we're there and one of the pledge
he told us when he was signing for
leadership was as someone who'd employed
thousands of people his door was always
open and
you know be nice if we could just just
go in and have you tried to see him
again
um I've messaged him a few times and
when I've had particularly terrible
abuse it got really really bad about a
year or so ago and he did phone me and
say he was sorry but I think he feels
very limited as to what he can do he
won't for example show public support uh
I guess all of the pressure from all of
the labor student groups and the labor
activists and most of them are but do
you think he believes himself I've got
no idea he's never given you any
indication no I don't know I don't know
what he thinks really
you're in a place where the labor party
look should be roaring to a pretty
comfortable beach in the next election
but this women's issue isn't going away
it's kind of ripping large parts of the
party apart in many ways yeah and I
don't want that of course I don't want
that but in 2019 I remember telling a
few people possibly care I don't know
but in 2019 there were two things on the
Dual step for me in Canterbury for exit
Jeremy corbyn and anti-Semitism in the
same sentence and it was very hard to to
win as an MP in 2019 as a labor MP as
you know the third thing that came up
was women taking me aside and asking to
tell me about their experiences one was
a social worker one was a teacher one
was just a mum and it was before way
before your Tweet before I said anything
in public and I took them aside and I
listened to them so I knew this is not
going away but when I tried to mention
it I was told to colleagues even I was
told it was a niche issue shouldn't be
talking about it we should be talking
about important things and big issues
when you saw for example I mean it seems
to me there's a lot of fronts the attack
is coming from at the moment yeah the
Brit Awards with the gender neutrality
issue which many people like me warned
at the time would almost certainly lead
to the awards actually being skewed more
to the men we'd have the opposite effect
to what people thought it would have
when you saw all the male artists
nominees were men this year what did you
think it's pretty depressing isn't it I
mean you know lots of us were talking
the women who haven't talked about the
gender critical side of things and and
the trans side of things are all really
angry about that but you know that's the
face of all of this if you change our
language if we don't get to protect our
spaces this is kind of where we're going
well if we don't take the word woman and
we don't celebrate Womanhood and we
don't celebrate femininity and being
female what's wrong with a best female
artist category if the trans Lobby group
wanted an award show have their own or
have their own category yeah I don't
mind if you know Sam Smith in one minute
he's a straight guy next minute he's a
gay guy next minute he wants us to call
him they them because he's non-binary I
don't give a damn what he wants to call
himself I do give a damn one his
campaigning means the brittle walls
decisive go gender-neutral and the
victims are women artists who've now
been completely evaporated for this
event really so gender neutral usually
means without women or women being
excluded C seen those signs on the news
that are tweeted and there's a disabled
sign and a woman's sign and a unisex
sign and then there's another door and
it's just got a man sign you think hang
on a sec and then you get to sport which
is even more depressing because
everybody knows how ridiculously unfair
this is everybody knows that just
reducing testosterone doesn't make any
difference most puberty to a man's body
mass his muscle his strength his lung
capacity I interviewed one of the
British champion shot putter last night
uh Amelia strickler and she was you know
really good actually we've got a little
clip I think of it from the interview
last night
I think we've got a clip of the
interview but she was great because she
she basically said look we're we're
going to end up I've got a hair now
they'll never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes female it's
a real issue even you know Dino this
summer said you know I've had lady
issues and she didn't perform well when
she didn't perform well that day and you
know it's understandable
I mean I hadn't even really thought
about that aspect of it but she's so
right is that trans women athletes don't
have that issue of a monthly period that
they have to deal with as athletes which
can't be very debilitating if not
performance reducing as we just heard
um again no thought given to this other
than we're going to get our way and we
don't care about women's rights here or
fairness and equality in their own
Stampede for what they see is fairness
and equality for their own Community the
trans Community they are creating a new
unfairness inequality absolutely My
friend Sharon Davis yeah I've spent a
lot of time
she's fantastic and she feels I think
I'm not putting words in her mouth I've
been to events where she's spoken that
what you know she missed out on a gold
medal partly because of the doping of
some of the Eastern European countries I
think she feels that she's reliving that
all over it we saw it with the New
Zealand weightlift female weightlifting
team where Laurel Hubbard who had
competed as a man before now got an
Olympic plays at the expense of a woman
born to a female body yeah that to me is
completely unfair Laurel Hubbard was
unsuccessful as a male competitor and
then suddenly as an Olympian yeah as a
woman and we've seen it in cycling well
there's a cricketer down in Kent
actually a six foot four inch cricketer
who was a male cricketer with an average
of 17 I think becomes a female female
cricketer and suddenly averages 120. wow
I was a cricket fan I find that utterly
ridiculous yeah I mean it's just not
fair like you said it's not a level
playing but if you say that you're a
trans foam apparently no I mean we've
talked in sports and circles you know I
know some sports psychologists who who
are really talking about this issue and
what about different categories because
this argument is in its infancy we
haven't got there yet we haven't found
Solutions but the solution isn't pushing
women aside it can't be
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
worship him or detest him it's usually
one of the two Donald Trump can never be
fully written off hammered by lawsuits
humbled in the midterm elections
hemorrhaging backers to his younger
rival Ron DeSantis Trump still believes
he can return to the White House and
return him to Facebook and Instagram
might be the first big step on an
explosive March back to Power
campaigning used to be about pounding
Pavements bashing phones kissing babies
heads now the heat is where we all spend
hours every day on social media that's
why Trump's banned from Twitter Facebook
and Instagram was seismic the take giant
suspended Trump for glorifying and in
their view inciting and Insurrection on
January 6 of the capital they choked off
his ability to spend hundreds of
millions of dollars riling and rousing
tens of millions of Voters the most
damaging for Trump they choked off his
ability to be the center of attention
this this was why they did it
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us from me from
you from our country this was a
fraudulent election but we can't play
into the hands of these people
we have to have peace
so go home we love you you're very
special
well it was a little bit late for that
wasn't it because people had already
started dying at the Capitol and it was
not righteously irresponsible thing that
Trump did in relation to that event he
whipped up his supporters into a frenzy
in the other steps aligned again then
I'm sure he will be banned again because
Free Speech always comes with some guard
rails you can't incite hatred demand
violence or shout fire in a crowded
theater but Banning Trump is at the
heart of a much bigger debate who gets
to decide what those guard rails are big
tech companies themselves are unelected
and unaccountable so why should they get
to make decisions that literally change
the outcome of Elections
a former leader of the Free World a man
who got 74 million votes in the last
election was banned for inciting
violence but the Ayatollah of Iran who
literally has called for America to be
wiped off the map still has a Twitter
account which he uses to spew Holocaust
denial and demand actual War the
Communist Party of China has used
Twitter to say its genocide against a
weaker Muslims is about setting them
free Putin's Kremlin still pumps out
propaganda even as the Russian army
blows up maternity hospitals in Ukraine
human rights abusing despots in
Venezuela and Saudi Arabia were deemed
acceptable too now billionaire Elon Musk
wants to fix this nonsense he spent 44
billion dollars buying Twitter and he
did that after one of his favorite
satirical websites Babylon B was
suspended this is what they do
what my mom got you an apron this
and an apron
patriarchal oppression and a shackles
civil normativity I belong in the world
toppling gender stereotypes
objectification inequality and the
subjugation of half the world's
population
[Music]
breaking news
War 3 has officially commenced as our
mission goes to war the president has
declared that one eagle-bodied member of
each American household will be drafted
into the military on the other hand
traditional gender roles exist for a
reason I'm your wife and I belong in the
kitchen
well you may not share any of my sense
of humor although actually I do uh
Babylon B which is a funny conservative
satirical site was actually banned for
posting that a trans woman in the US
government Rachel Levine was one of
their men of the year you might not find
that funny you might even find it
offensive that's your right but is he
really more offensive than the Ayatollah
of Iran tweeting that Israel should be
incinerated
too often the musicians are taken by
chin stroking bearded hipsters you voted
for Bernie Sanders and think Trump is
the devil banned people for breaking the
law not because they're not woke enough
well joining me now is host of podcasts
are Cara Swisher Seth Dillon CEO of the
statistical website Babylon B who met
Trump actually this week to discuss all
this uh and we've got my pack as well
the broadcaster Alex Phillips Lauren
commentator Paula Roan Adrian and talk
to the international editor Isabel
eggshell so a stellar panel of frenzied
social media uses on my ad have all been
gathered to debate all this uh let me
start with you Seth Dylan because you're
really one of the reasons that Elon Musk
ended up buying Twitter if you believe
his tweets because he was incense that
people like you were getting effectively
censored and banned by the former
Twitter regime and that this was only
ever skewed towards conservatives
well yeah I don't think that we were the
sole reason that he did that I think he
was primarily concerned about restoring
free speech and we were one egregious
example of how just making jokes you
know making jokes that you're not
supposed to make was resulting in
suspensions where our speech was being
curbed so uh you know he saw that as
problematic and wanted to step in and do
something about it and I I think it's a
great thing that he did somebody needed
to as Bill Maher said Twitter needs a
new sheriff they weren't doing a very
good job deciding what's true and what's
right and what's hateful yeah well I can
really agree and it always seemed to be
skewed one way towards people on the
right so Carl Swisher I mean that was my
experience as somebody who sits you know
pretty much in the middle a lot to
consider myself I I was watching this
thinking well it is only actually people
on the right who were getting slung off
Twitter it's only people like Babylon
but it's only people like Donald Trump
it's never the hardcore left who
sometimes can be just as outrageous and
defensive
well you know the Babylon bee thing was
ridiculous I would agree that they
shouldn't have been kicked off I mean
you can think it's the joke was funny or
not but it was there was nothing wrong
with having satire and things like that
on there and I think it gets more
problematic when you have someone like
Donald Trump possibly uh promoting
violence and that's the problem here is
that they have these rules and they were
they were just they were never they were
random and that's the problem with it I
don't necessarily think there's any
beard stroking Bernie Sanders person I
think that's a Trope also
um but that they were randomly
um put in place and there's actually
been some new reporting also that they
they were too scared to take things down
too of conservatives and I think that's
the problem is that these companies were
unaccountable to anyone as you noted
um have no ability to make rules that
they stick to and that's that's the
problem with Facebook too they sort of
did this two-year ban what's a two-year
ban what does that mean
um because they they didn't have the
guts to kick them off I guess or not or
I don't don't kick them off if you don't
think it's a real ban and so I think the
problem is these are make being made by
singular people uh even if it's Elon
Musk he had the same problem this week
with Nick Fuentes he brought him back on
and he kicked him right off
um
yeah Kanye West I think it's going to be
a problem forever because they make
these rules they don't enforce them and
then they change them and nothing makes
sense and that that to me is the real
problem is that you're putting people in
place that don't have any business
making decisions for the rest of society
including real societal harm uh possible
yeah I don't disagree with that I mean
Seth Dillon you were actually with
Donald Trump uh yesterday I think um you
were having dinner with him what was his
view about whether he should come back
onto social media because obviously he's
had the invitation to come back to
Twitter which he hasn't taken yet
because he has his own truth social
media platform but did you get a feeling
he is going to come steaming back
I'm not sure I don't know that he's made
that decision yet
um but he shares the concern that a lot
of Americans can share that there's
politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination happening on these
platforms he was a victim of it we've
been a victim of it you know it whether
it goes one way or not I don't think is
really the issue
um sure it's a problem if it's if it's
one-sided the rules aren't being applied
fairly but this is the the Public Square
of the Modern Age where people need to
be able to have a voice there's a recent
case that just happened you know you had
this house bill 20 was passed in Texas
where they were trying to make
politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination illegal and an Obama
appointed judge enjoined that law and
then the fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
looked at it they said no listen there
is no hidden right to censor in the
First Amendment censorship isn't speech
so these platforms don't have a
constitutional right to be able to
censor you they need to let you speak
and express your viewpoints they
shouldn't be deciding what's true they
shouldn't be moderating jokes because
they think the jokes are hateful and
saying things like when Trump got kicked
off Twitter people don't know this but
Trump got kicked off Twitter for saying
I won't be attending the inauguration
and he said my supporters will have a
voice long into the future what role
does that supposedly violate it's not
unlawful speech it's not inciting anyone
it's not calling for anything you have
to read that into it and that's the
problem is you can you should be able to
express your opinions say what you
believe even if it's not true you have a
right to be wrong Hillary Clinton said
that his election in 2016 was
illegitimate she had every right to say
that if she wanted to say that she's
going to make that point is it it was
exactly the same thing about that they
all said that that election was stolen
from them there was no qualitative
differences
not accurate
you know look it was slightly different
but to me the generalized sort of
overview of it all it's a little much
difference between one group of people
saying but it's different directions let
me say one thing first of all you're
saying it's a Public Square it's not a
Public Square it's a profit-making
business they can do whatever they want
you can do whatever you want you don't
have any right to be on Twitter you
don't have any right to be on Facebook
and I think that's the problem is we've
become to think of it as that I think
the real problem is when the government
does intervene including in Texas which
is going to get a going to be an
overrule because of the First Amendment
they should also be able to put on what
they want and I think the problem is
everyone's decided they own these things
we did start the internet the U.S
taxpayer paid for the internet and
that's for sure but these businesses can
do whatever they want the real problem
it seems to me the most egregious
example I think of what was going on was
the New York Post expose day of Hunter
Biden agree and that laptop several
weeks before that election uh where we
don't know what would have happened if
if Twitter hadn't banned the New York
Post site completely and basically
airbrushed that expose which turned out
to it right but that was let me just say
that was yeah but I changed it really
quickly they you and I have talked about
this they change it really quickly they
said they made a mistake he said it in
Congress
in Dominion I didn't change it until
after the election and the big
unanswerable question now is what impact
would it have had if the mainstream
media had not all convinced themselves
this was Russian propaganda and had
actually gone after that story as
aggressively as they should have done
three weeks before an election it could
have tilted things Trump's way so you
actually had a direct example of a
social media platform Banning a story
and a newspaper from publishing that
true story which could have influenced
the result of an election
and you have the same thing with Fox and
Dominion should they have been able to
broadcast those election things I mean I
think that's the problem is that these
sites have so much power over everyone
and yet they're private companies and so
what is the what is the solution in the
case of Babylon Bay it takes Elon Musk
to buy it and let them back on and
that's the solution unfortunately a
billionaire has to buy it
um I think the problem is is we've
gotten we have these private uh profit
making companies making decisions for
all of society and by the way they're
allowed to even if they make a mistake
even if they make the wrong call even if
they say we need to make a distinction
though we need to make a distinction
between how it is and how it should be
and like you just acknowledged these
private companies exercise a ton of
power the primary threat to speech used
to be the government but now because
people speak online the primary threat
to speech is these online forums that
are owned by private companies and the
question like justice Thomas is asking
is should SEC should a common carrier
Doctrine apply to them should we have
rules in place regulations in place
where uh discriminate nation is
prohibited I think a good argument can
be made the common carrier Doctrine
could and should apply to these private
companies even though they're privately
owned so that people are not
discriminated against unfairly and they
still have a voice let me ask you let me
ask you where do where do you think the
line is with freedom of speech nobody I
don't think believes it should be
completely
unfilled in other words that anything
goes for example
well Kanye West for example when he
literally is brought back on Twitter and
one of the first things he does is post
the Star of David with a swastika inside
it if you were running Twitter even with
your Zeal for free speech which I share
would you have tolerated that
well I do think there's a place for
moderation I think that you get into
really tricky places when you try to
moderate people's opinions I think that
people have a right to opinions even
opinions that are wrong opinion that's a
deliberate attempt but you can I mean
that's not an opinion is it yeah it's
just that's basically inciting Nazi
hatred against the Jewish people through
symbolism isn't it yeah and these
platforms should be able to moderate
content that they believe is obscene and
objectively offensive that isn't
Viewpoint related I think they
absolutely should be able to they should
be able to moderate unlawful speech I
think that they give people a lot of
tools for example if you say things that
upset me all the time if you're trolling
me or making fun of me and making me
feel bad I can block you I can mute you
I have that control and I can control
who I see and who I hear from Leave it
in people's hands what they see what
they consume let them reach their own
decisions stop trying to decide for them
what's true what they're allowed to joke
about what they're allowed to believe
the thought control and speech control
that these private companies are
exercising right now is having
detrimental effects in society
just want to ask you one question
because you were at this dinner with
with Trump and in the background of the
picture of one of the other people you
were with the libs of tick tock I think
they call themselves they mock liberal
people for doing silly things uh in the
background yeah there's a picture of
what looked like Nick Clegg who's the
spokesman for Facebook who know well
over here was it Nick Clegg was he there
I'm not sure I wasn't aware of that and
I don't know who else was present I
gotta say it looks either it's Nick leg
or it's a dead ringer for Nick clay
which prompts all sorts of questions
what the hell was he doing there anyway
I'm gonna leave it there with you too
this was great thank you both very much
because you're both very tapped into all
this it is a complex thing I personally
am very glad Elon Musk is wrestling
through it because I think he comes from
a good place about it but we'll see he's
he's found out pretty quickly it's tough
it's tough in the jungle uh bakara and
so thank you both very much indeed and
Seth great to have you back on Twitter I
missed I've missed Babylon B you're
hilarious uh so good to see you man
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]